you're at home watching a movie maybe
it's a great film maybe it's just a
guilty pleasure but you know for sure
there's that one scene you just don't
want to watch it's too cringe-worthy too
scary too disturbing too stupid or even
too boring so you grab the remote so you
can fast forward to the next watchable
scene don't worry everyone's done it
here are some of the movie moments that
many of us prefer to skip right over
spoilers ahead of course Jaws this
Steven Spielberg classic still gives
everyone shark nightmares and it all
stems from its opening scene the poor
doomed Crissy goes for a moonlight
skinny dip after a party on the beach we
see something approached her dangling
legs from under the water and you could
probably guess where it goes from there
with terror in her eyes she's whipped
around for what seems like forever
screaming things like until she's
finally pulled under for good better to
just move along because we all know the
real fun of Jaws is watching Brody
Hooper and Quint on the boat hashing it
out with the shark Scarface the rags to
riches story of a Cuban immigrant who
becomes a drug lord only to see his
empire crumble at his bloodied cocaine
caked feet it's a given that Scarface is
a very violent experience but one scene
featuring a chainsaw takes it to another
level early in the game some seriously
pissed-off Colombians show Tony Montana
why you don't mess with them sure there
are plenty of horror movies that use
this particular tool to gruesome effect
and you may choose to skip over those
scenes as well but when it comes to the
Scarface chainsaw scene you'll
definitely want to sit this one out
misery you don't really see it coming
but when wackadoo Annie decides she
needs to teach her favorite author Paul
a lesson after he breaks her rules it's
pretty horrifying with Paul tied to a
bed with a wooden block between his feet
and he starts talking about how he needs
a good hobbling to make him realize he
can never leave her and then she takes a
sledgehammer and crushes his ankles on
both sides Wow it's just too painful to
watch
by the way in Stephen King's novel and
he does far worse things to poor Paul
but you can skip past those pages as
well marathon man anyone who's seen
marathon man probably gets a toothache
just thinking about it
this superb crime thriller film C's
graduate student babe caught up in a spy
game that involves a Nazi war criminal a
skilled dentist whose specialty in the
concentration camps was well you get the
picture
he captures babe and torches him all
while asking his it's no it's not safe
and anyone with a dentist phobia which
is pretty much everyone will probably
push that fast-forward button 127 hours
if you know the true story of Aaron
Ralston a mountain climber who became
trapped under a boulder while hiking
alone you know the desperate measures he
had to take in order to survive played
by James Franco in the film Aaron has to
sawed off part of his arm in order to
free himself and stay alive when it
comes to that moment in 127 hours you
think you're prepared but you're really
not director Danny Boyle masterfully
captures the essence of the scene
Franco brilliantly plays ER and they
should be applauded for it but no one
needs to watch it again
2001 a Space Odyssey look we all know
this 1968 Stanley Kubrick film was way
ahead of its time when it was released
and is widely regarded as a cinematic
classic from a master director it is a
spectacularly visual film worthy of its
praise but man that first 10 minutes
with the Apes and the black monolith
will put you right to sleep I don't know
what you're talking about just skip all
that and get to the meat of the film in
which a ship computer goes creepily
rogue after it realizes the humans might
turn it off in the Battle of evil
computers versus dumb monkeys computers
always win thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you love to
[Music]